aux abords de la ville de soleda l'armée
ukrainienne pilonne les positions de
l'adversaire dans le ciel les chasseurs
russeries postent à leur tour la Russie
tente coûte que coûte de changer le
cours de la guerre
situé dans la région de Donetsk et non
loin de la ville clé de barmut cette
cité minière de 10 000 habitants et le
théâtre de violon combat mais aussi de
lutte d'influence entre la milice
paramilitaire Wagner et l'armée russe le
groupe de mercenaires russes revendique
d'abord la prise de Solidar avec cette
photo mais l'information est tout de
suite démentie par l'armée russe et
également par les autorités ukrainiennes
et ses propagandistes tentent de faire
croire que l'assaut sur notre ville de
soledar presque entièrement détruite par
les occupants est une sorte de réussite
militaire de la Russie c'est la version
qu'il donne à leur population afin de
soutenir la mobilisation et pour donner
de l'espoir à ceux qui soutiennent cette
guerre mais les combats continuent
l'Ukraine réitère ses appels à ses
partenaires occidentaux pour recevoir
des armements lourds et de l'ont portées